Cobra Kai returns Friday on Netflix for
their Fifth Season I mean this is a
runaway train and who better to talk
about it than the Stars themselves Ralph
Macchio and William zapka and uh guys
season five can you believe it do you
kind of like knock on wood a little bit
yeah we knock on each other a lot and a
lot of wood yeah you guys have known
each other for 40 years well you know 30
something hey hey sure sure the 49. hey
look at that what were your first
impressions of each other he scared the
crap out of it
I was a fan of his from Outsiders so
when I met him I was like that's guy
from outside
like the Mist is what's pretty you know
how is it to still be fighting after all
these years you're still fighting you're
still out there getting in the mix how
is it doing these fight scenes well I'm
just holding takes a little more time to
get warmed up um you know to stay limber
it's like ice tub yeah
Epsom salt bass every day yeah lots of
Motrin we're good yeah is there any
chance because people are also asking
for other characters to come back like
Hilary Swank they don't always tell us
everything but I think the door is
always open she's in the universe
anybody in the Miyagi verse
Miyagi exactly is game for it you know
what do you think Pat Morita would think
of this series now I think you would
love it I think he's watching it yeah I
think he is is a blessing somewhere we
feel we feel his presence on the set all
the time is there any chance that there
could be a movie now that the show is
such a hit yeah could we get a movie
that's what we're all leading up to
isn't it we're negotiating that right
now break the news guys
anything's possible who knows yeah
[Music]